welcome back to las vegas now want to
look younger but
don't know where to start a good way to
do that could be you know just to visit
blue blue point medical spa mercedes
shows us how
take a look
if you are ready to gift yourself the
gift of beautiful skin
blue point medical spa has so many
incredible treatments and one we have
been hearing about
a lot lately is called old therapy
jennifer quinn from blue point is here
to tell us more about it what is
all therapy all therapy is our
non-invasive
non-surgical treatment that we use to
help tighten and lift the skin
is fda approved for the forehead for the
mid face
and for the neck as well so we have this
beautiful patient who wants to tighten
the skin that looks around like her jaw
area
how is this working right now what are
we doing here
melissa is treating the jowl
areas by basically putting little tiny
burns into the tissue
and she's using the screen to kind of
guide her
with the treatment now what kind
of down time are we going to see i know
the results
are incredible is she going to be out
for a while
well with this treatment there is no
down time
she may feel a little swollen she may
have a little birth but she can go
after this and go work out and go back
to work and
be able to enjoy her day the results
really do speak for themselves do you
see the results right away
or does it take some time for them to
kick in well that's the thing is the
collagen takes time
to build so this will take about three
to six months just like when you work
out
the muscle it takes a few months for you
to see the results so
it's a minimum again three months to
start seeing the results and then it
takes up to six months to see the max
results
what age do you think is best to have
old therapy done
well i think it's good for all ages
um somebody that's in their late
twenties can start doing treatments like
this to
prevent aging and you know if you
prevent it it's a lot easier than trying
to correct
um someone that's in there's you know
later age when they see the sagging
it's good to come in if they're not
ready to do the face lift yet
so they can again come in have a
treatment and then be able to go enjoy
their day
so jennifer how many treatments does the
average patient need
to experience great results well
from the range of age younger
patients will need one every other year
and our more mature patients will need
one
about every year now right now blue
point medical spa is offering a great
special on all therapy what is it our
special is
75 off our regular price and that is
going
from now until the end of march did you
say
75 off i did 75
off that is quite a deal and the results
they speak for themselves so make sure
you check out all
therapy at blue point medical spa
again that's blue point medical spa it's
located on buffalo drive
give them a call at 702-307-3330
to make your appointment just visit them
online at bluepointmedicalspa.com and
take advantage of that special mercedes
mentioned
75 off all ultra therapy
treatments through the end of march las
vegas now we'll be right back